[Musique]
ah les regarde je te mets ton film qui
est scooby doo
les gens qui la prennent en général nous
disent ah si si si il nous faut la télé
parce que mon chien il regarde la télé
plus vite plus au moins fort telle
pourrait être la devise des prochains jo
de tokyo fin juillet en effet les
organisateurs ont décidé d'accueillir du
public dans les tribunes
dix mille personnes maximum uniquement
des japonais mais ces derniers n'auront
pas le droit je cite de montrer leur
satisfaction de crier ou de parler à
haute voix vous êtes vacciné ou pas moi
je suis vacciné moi j'en ai encore
discuté ce matin avec jean marie bigard
on est tous les deux d'accord sur le
sujet le tu as this c'est meilleur que
la chloroquine je suis pas sûr que ce
soit le message à faire passer
ouais ta gueule croire en dieu pas dans
les vaccins
peut-on lire sur le tee shirt de mike
tyson un texte assorti d'une seringue
barré eh bien il s'agit là encore d'un
photomontage les photos originales date
en réalité de novembre 2020
le boxeur les avais posté vous le voyez
sur instagram pour jean-marc pour ces
petites bêtes lie un vaccin
oui je crois que je crois qu'il ya des
choses mais lui il a pas envie pour
l'instant voilà enfin je fais ce que je
veux je me dis peut-être que dans sa
chambre reprochera peut pas avoir
augmenter les efforts dans la recherche
médicale parce qu'il y aura un virus
qu'on n'a pas vu venir
tu vois tu peux prendre le pari là
dessus peut-être que dans cinq ans
quelqu'un viendra me dire mais vous
n'avez pas vu que les russes ils
allaient envahir la pologne
non mais je dis n'importe quoi layton au
canada dévorée par les flammes
un dôme de chaleur et tout flamme eric
du nord et une tornade ravage plusieurs
villages de la république tchèque
ces phénomènes extrêmes observés ces
dernières semaines sont ils liés au
réchauffement de la planète
nicolas hulot finalement est-ce que
l'écologie ne pâtit pas des écologistes
49° cinq au canada 34 degrés 7 à moscou
et un exceptionnel 48 degrés en sibérie
pourtant considérée comme l'une des
régions les plus froides de la terre on
peut toujours reprocher la méthode les
moyens en face on les avait écoutés
depuis longtemps plutôt que de se moquer
sans argument autre argument on n'en
serait pas là
certains bien alcoolisés ont du mal à
partir
ils sont expulsés manu militari le site
ressemble à une déchetterie à ciel
ouvert on va bosser toute la nuit
jusqu'à 8h du matin avait tout doit
partir au coeur du golfe du mexique
scène apocalyptique un oeil de feu à la
surface de l'océan sous l'eau c'est en
fait une canalisation de gaz qui fuient
l'incident s'est produit hier matin en
pleine zone d'exploitation pétrolière
offshore
on parle de mes missions de santé un
donc c'est dans le corps humain et plus
particulièrement dans le coeur des
hommes
ah les femmes n'ont pas je vous aide à
l'intelligence le cerveau non mais c'est
pour rire c'est pour rire je le dis on
la laissait millésime gauchistes pendant
votre question à bras tu veux que je te
poses des questions gauchistes non non
non non non vas-y vas-y posez votre
question toujours de droite
regardez cette belle prostate qui tourne
il passa comme vous ne l'aviez jamais vu
ba s'était dit bien qu'ils aient tous il
débarrassé pas la table il faisait pas
les courses moi c'était un peu de
seniors nantes on s'explique non moi je
viens du jeu vient d'une famille où il y
avait du personnel
donc quand je me suis marié je me suis
retrouvé un peu
comme ça moi c'est vrai je disais j'ai
épousé un prince sans ça bougeait pas
allez-vous rétablir l'impôt de
solidarité sur la fortune pour faire
payer les riches parce que bavaria
rideau mortiers je pense que je suis
tyrannique tyrannique
oui c'est bon t'as fait le bois demain
c'est le jardin pour tous vous pensez
d'aplomb mais parce que j'ai dit la
vérité et lui l'a pas droit d'accord
conséquence à l'heure du bilan il y en a
un qui voit un paysage plus beaux claude
dans leurs trous ça vient marcher parce
que moi je faisais un boulot rocheman
intéressant et puis elle elle s'occupait
magnifiquement des enfants avec toute
son énergie est extraordinaire parce qu
est ce que tu veux de muretaine de la
chance monsieur jolie femme en face
allô allô jolie femme on lui parle on
laisse le téléphone christian peut se
permettre de taquiner ses clients son
restaurant est une institution à
saint-jean-de-luz jolies femmes volent
en profite
vous verrez après elle se barre et on
fait la gueule elle n'en revient
toujours pas mais le 20 juillet prochain
waly faye 82 ans va réaliser le rêve
d'une vie
enfin invitée par le milliardaire jeff
bezos
elle inaugurera le premier vol habité de
sa société de tourisme spatial blue
origin
ça valait bien un petit câlin 60 ans que
sept pilotes aguerris remué ciel et
terre pour devenir astronaute
en vain pendant des années malgré des
tests réussis qu on lui a expliqué que
l'espace ce n'était pas une affaire de
femmes ils m'ont dit vous êtes une femme
vous ne pouvez pas faire ça j'ai répondu
tout est possible si on veut vraiment
j'aime faire ce que personne n'a fait
avant moi
belga
et c'est quoi cette pancarte en fait
pour avoir des câlins gratuits
c'est les cas l'armée
[Applaudissements]
des câlins gratuits d'un côté
win please oui de crise
mais je suis désolé mais il faut que je
mange moi j'ai pas mangé ce matin et
j'ai pas mangé hier soir donc suffi à
montrouge et ce en quoi c'était ma
question mais qui qui a mis lyon 11
heures 30 ans si bien alors qu il est
13h fait ses débuts à 11h30 à 13h
[Applaudissements]